هل تحتفل بعيد الحب
جيدًا ، فقد ترغب في الدخول في دائرة في ذلك اليوم
في عام 2046 لأن مكتب الدفاع الكوكبي التابع لناسا
يتعقب كويكبًا جديدًا
لديه فرصة ضئيلة جدًا لضرب الأرض
في غضون 23 عامًا ، وينضم إلي الآن ديفيد
فارنوشيا ، وهو مهندس ملاحة في
وكالة ناسا  مختبر الدفع النفاث أه
دافيدا ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك على انضمامك إلينا ،
وأود أن أبدأ بسؤالك
عن هذا الكويكب المكتشف حديثًا 20 ،
واسم هذا الكويكب هو uh 2023 DW
بناءً على خبرتك وخبرتك ،
وكم من الخطر يحدث  هذا يمثل
لكوكب الأرض ،
لا يتعلق هذا الكائن بشكل خاص بالأه
أنه تم اكتشافه في
26 فبراير وفي مختبر الدفع النفاث التابع لناسا على
وجه الخصوص في مركز
دراسات الأجسام القريبة من الأرض ،
نتتبع هذه الأشياء وكلما كان هناك
اكتشاف جديد قابلناه  المسار خلال
المائة عام القادمة وتحقق مما إذا
كان هناك احتمال بعيد للتأثير
في معظم الحالات ، وجدنا أن التأثير
غير ممكن ، يمكننا استبعاد ذلك
بسرعة كبيرة في هذه الحالة ، لا يمكننا فعل ذلك
ومع ذلك نحتاج إلى المزيد من البيانات من أجل  الوصول إلى هذه
النقطة ولكن لدينا
احتمال تأثير صغير جدًا بنسبة 0.2 في المائة لعام 2046.
أود دائمًا أن أضع الأشياء بطريقة أخرى ،
فهناك احتمال بنسبة 99.8 في المائة
ألا يصل الجسم إلى
الأرض
جيدًا ، وهذا أمر رائع لسماعه ولكنك
تعرف في أي وقت يكون فيه كويكب على الأقل
في بعض الأهداف مع بعض احتمالية
ضرب الأرض ، فأنت تعلم أنه يجعل
أبناء الأرض يلاحظون
أن هذا الكويكب يبلغ عرضه حوالي 50 مترًا تقريبًا
بحجم
حوض سباحة أولمبي ،
لماذا تم اكتشافه فقط في
فبراير  لأنني أعلم أن هذا
مصدر قلق لدى وكالة ناسا بشأن احتمال
اكتشاف الكويكبات في وقت متأخر عما
يودون ،
لذا فإن هذا الجسم لا يتجاوز 50 مترًا ، فهذا
يعني أنه يحتاج حقًا إلى الاقتراب
بما يكفي من الأرض حتى نلتقطه
وأه كان لدينا  أن تنتظر حتى
فبراير الماضي للحصول على أول فرصة جيدة
لاكتشافها ولكن أه وكالة ناسا
مكلفة حقًا باكتشاف أكثر من
90 كائنًا 140 مترًا أو أكثر
لأن تلك هي التي يمكن أن
تسبب ضررًا كبيرًا ، هذا
صغير إلى حد ما و  وهي فائدة جانبية
لبحثنا عن الكويكبات وحقيقة
أنه يمكننا اكتشاف جسم
صغير بهذا الحجم مع احتمال تأثير صغير في عام
2046 يشبه 20 أكثر من 20 عامًا من
المهلة وهذه علامة جيدة جدًا على ما
تفعله في  اكتشاف
الأشياء ، نعم تمامًا ، لذلك أفهم أنني
أريد فقط أن أكرر
فرصة ضئيلة جدًا للغاية أن هذا
ضرب الأرض ولكن دعنا نقول فقط عن طريق
الصدفة أنه تسبب في نوع الضرر الذي قد يتسبب فيه
كويكب بهذا الحجم على بعد 50 مترًا
جيدًا على ما أعتقد  التناظرية الجيدة هي
مصادم تونجوسكا الذي حدث في عام 1908
والذي كان له تأثير على روسيا
والذي أدى إلى تسطيح الأشجار على مساحة 2000
كيلومتر مربع لذلك هذا هو نوع
التناظرية ولكن مرة أخرى كما قلت ،
فإن الاحتمال ضئيل حقًا بمجرد أن
نحصل على  البيانات الجديدة سنكون
قادرين على صقل الحسابات المدارية
وتحديث تقييم المخاطر
والفرص سنكون قادرين على
استبعاد هذا الاحتمال
بالتأكيد سريعًا
سؤالًا إضافيًا لك لمركبة الفضاء الكبيرة التابعة لناسا
والمركبة الفضائية النبيلة  الذي أصاب
ذلك الكويكب ونجح في إبعاده عن
مساره في وقت سابق أه أو
أعتقد في نوفمبر من العام الماضي أه
أول مهمة اختبار دفاع كوكبي أه هل
يمكن استخدام هذا النوع من التكنولوجيا أه
لدفع كويكب مثل هذا
بالتأكيد هذا هو السبب بالذات  لماذا
قمنا بهذه المهمة التي أردنا رؤيتها
وإثبات أن لدينا القدرة على
تحريك كويكب بالطبع في حال
احتجنا إلى القيام بذلك وكانت تلك المهمة
نجاحًا مذهلاً ، فقد كانت
نقطة جذب جميلة